Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
C'était quand la dernière fois que
vous avez eu peur de parler en public ?
Vous avez eu des papillons dans le ventre,
les mains moites
et les joues qui chauffent.
Parler en public,
c'est la deuxième peur de l'Homme,
juste après la mort.
Alors si vous avez peur de temps en temps,
ben, c'est normal !
Jusqu'en 2011,
j'étais responsable de congrès.
j'achetais des conférenciers,
je les côtoyais, des centaines.
Certains géraient très très bien la peur,
d'autres en revanche,
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué.
Et parfois, ils devenaient
vraiment très désagréables.
Je vous laisse imaginer.
À cette époque, souvent,
je rentrais dans la régie, tout doucement,
derrière Gilbert,
qui me demandait souvent de sortir,
et là, j'écoutais.
Très vite, j'étais fixée,
et souvent, je repartais dans mon bureau.
Des conférences qui avaient
l'air tellement bien sur le papier,
en fait, elles étaient
livrées avec un style plat.
Je n'étais pas du tout,
mais pas du tout, captivée.
J'ai eu quand même quelques
belles expériences, je vous rassure.
Et du coup, j'ai décidé d'en partager
trois avec vous aujourd'hui.
Trois conférenciers qui m'ont
appris beaucoup de choses,
qui m'ont impactée.
Trois conférenciers
qui se posent une question
principale chacun.
Je suis venue vous les
donner, ces questions,
pour que vous puissiez
aussi, à partir de demain,
peut-être même ce soir,
devenir des orateurs bien plus inspirants,
clairs,
et structurés.
C'est parti ?
Je vous emmène
en Afrique du Sud,
avec Ian Thomas.
Ian, il gère une réserve animalière.
Il adore les lions,
alors ce qu'il fait, lui, c'est
qu'il étudie les meutes de lions,
leur fonctionnement,
et il transporte ça dans des équipes
qui sont très performantes.
Ian, sa force : il raconte des histoires,
il vous fait vivre des émotions.
Alors, il plante le décor,
on est avec lui dans la savane,
on est en train de boire
cette eau boueuse, et on
a ce goût dans la bouche,
on a la fraîcheur de la nuit.
Et dans la journée, lorsqu'il
nous décrit cette savane,
on a là la chaleur qui nous transperce.
On a aussi parfois
les herbes,
les hautes herbes de la savane
qui nous frottent le museau -
j'ai bien dit « museau »,
parce qu'à ce moment, on est un lion.
Ian, il se met en scène.
Ça vaut le coup, hein !
Il traverserait toute la scène ici.
Parfois, il est à l'affût ;
parfois, il avance à pas feutrés ;
ou alors il bondit !
Et là, ce qu'il fait,
c'est qu'il agit sur 55% de son impact.
55%, vous imaginez ?
Ce dont on se rappelle
dans ses conférences,
c'est tout cet environnement,
ses histoires et ses gestes.
Et ça compte pour 55% !
Alors, si vous ne le faites pas,
vous laissez tout simplement la moitié
de votre impact dans les coulisses.
Ian, ce qu'il fait aussi,
c'est qu'il met du rythme.
Et ça, il le fait grâce au dialogue
entre ses gardes.
Il y a John et Martin.
Et ils dialoguent.
Et parfois, il appelle son lion préféré :
« Big black ! »
Ça crée des ruptures de rythme.
Et toutes ces ruptures de rythme
font qu'on est captivé,
que nos oreilles se tendent.
Il utilise aussi les pauses,
le silence.
C'est important parce que
ça crée une boucle de mémoire.
Autrement dit, chaque fois qu'un
conférencier dit quelque chose d'important
et qu'il fait un silence,
le public répète dans sa tête
et mémorise.
[Inaudible] C'est incroyable !
Et quand on travaille sur sa voix,
qu'on fait des rythmes différents,
on travaille juste sur
38% de notre impact.
C'est quand même aussi important.
Donc on a 55%,
on a 38%,
il reste combien alors ?
Il y a des matheux dans la salle ?
Il reste 7%.
Sept !
Sept, c'est le pouvoir des mots.
Alors, il faut bien les choisir,
mais sachez que vos mots et les mots
que je prononce en ce moment,
dans vos mémoires,
demain, la semaine prochaine,
ça comptera pour...
7%.
Tout de suite, on est
beaucoup plus modeste.
Ian, la question qu'il se pose, lui,
c'est : « Qu'est-ce que je veux
que les gens ressentent ? »
Et c'est ma première question, qui
est mon premier cadeau pour vous.
À chaque intervention, demandez-vous ce
que vous voulez que les gens ressentent.
Pour faire ça, le plus simple,
c'est raconter des histoires
ou mettre des dialogues,
parce que vous allez vivre
vos histoires, et qu'en les vivant,
vous allez faire passer
ces émotions dans votre public,
et du coup, ça les fera vibrer.
Mon conseil aussi,
c'est quand vous commencez à parler,
vous vous mettez bien
droit devant votre public,
vous faites un beau silence,
un geste d'ouverture et vous y allez,
avec une introduction qui va
droit au but.
Une belle introduction,
ça peut être une histoire,
une statistique,
une anecdote,
une affirmation,
mais elle doit aller droit au but.
Vous pouvez aussi -
et ça, c'est très simple -
vous imaginez que vous parlez à un public
qui n'entend pas très bien,
ni ne voit très bien non plus.
Vous n'avez pas de bol ce jour-là !
Au contraire, c'est un vrai
cadeau, parce que, du coup,
vous devez forcer un petit peu le trait,
vous devez un peu exagérer.
Et en exagérant un tout petit peu,
vous serez beaucoup mieux.
Même si on est très bien avec Ian
en Afrique du Sud,
on va partir
en Suisse,
avec une femme
incroyable et extraordinaire
que j'admire profondément.
Carla del Ponte.
A l'époque, elle est
procureur général en Suisse,
elle est membre de la Commission
anti-criminalité économique.
Je peux vous dire qu'en
Suisse, elle a un peu de travail.
Elle est invitée
par des banquiers suisses.
80 dans la salle.
Imaginez qu'ici, ce soir, vous tous des
banquiers suisses, des patrons de banque.
Là, il y a Paul,
là, il y a Michel,
ce sont ses gardes du corps.
Elle a loué quatre
chambres dans notre hôtel ;
on ne sait pas où elle dort.
Elle est devant eux,
elle les fixe,
et elle leur dit :
« Vous êtes responsables
d'une partie de la menace
qui pèse sur moi. »
Il y a eu un blanc dans la salle.
Elle a voulu provoquer
un vrai choc émotionnel
et elle avait un objectif très très clair.
Mon objectif, les faire collaborer.
Alors, vous aussi,
chaque fois que vous parlez,
demandez-vous ce que vous
voulez que les gens fassent.
Ça, c'est mon deuxième cadeau,
ma deuxième phrase-clé,
ma deuxième question-clé :
que voulez-vous que les gens fassent ?
Autrement dit : quelle est l'action
que vous voulez déclencher ?
Moi, mon action, c'est que vous
ayez envie de parler en public
et que vous utilisiez mes trois clés.
On va quitter la Suisse
pour la France
à la rencontre d'une femme
qui s'appelle Christine Morlet.
Depuis que j'ai quitté ce travail
de responsable de congrès,
je travaille avec elle.
Et si je suis là aujourd'hui,
c'est grâce à elle.
Elle est tombée malade
et a dû être hospitalisée.
Elle m'a dit : « On ne peut pas
laisser TEDxRoanne en plan,
tu y vas. »
Alors me voilà.
Christine, c'est une
conférencière de contenus.
Ce qui lui importe,
c'est à qui elle parle.
C'est sa question,
elle se le demande tout le temps,
parce qu'avec cette question,
elle va se demander
quelles sont les attentes
de son public - que veut-il ?
Quand vous allez repartir ce soir, avec
quoi vous voulez partir dans les poches ?
Et évidemment, dans ces conférences,
pour avoir beaucoup d'impact, elle,
elle va répondre à ces attentes
et à ces questions.
Au-delà de ça, j'avais
une question pour vous :
est-ce que vous avez
tous amené votre cerveau ?
Ouais ; j'entends des rires.
Je vois des hochements,
on est partis.
On va aller voir ce que ça
veut dire dans le cerveau.
On a tous notre façon d'appréhender
l'information ; ici, il y en a plusieurs.
Il y a des gens qui vont
ressentir les choses,
d'autres qui vont les intellectualiser,
d'autres qui vont faire
confiance à leur intuition,
et d'autres enfin,
se fier à leur logique.
Et dans cette salle, vous vous posez tous
une question précise, voire deux.
Vous vous posez quatre questions, en fait.
La première, c'est : quoi ?
C'est quoi, TED ?
On a eu la réponse tout à l'heure.
Comment ça marche ?
Cette journée est organisée comment ?
Et à quelle heure c'est la pause ?
C'est qui, cette jeune femme -
pas tout à fait jeune, d'ailleurs… -
qui se promène devant nous ?
Elle est maman ?
Et pourquoi je suis là ?
Pourquoi un samedi après-midi,
j'ai décidé d'être là ?
Ça doit sûrement avoir
un bénéfice pour moi dans le futur.
Si vous répondez à ces quatre questions,
vous avez déjà pas mal de clés.
Mais au-delà de ça,
il y a une autre méthode
qui est vraiment infaillible,
et je vais vous la donner.
D'abord,
on est dans l'émotionnel et, avec
une belle intro, on va créer le lien.
On va prendre le public dans ses bras.
Quand c'est un garçon dans la rue
qui veut aborder une fille,
s'il lui fait une bise tout de suite...
(Bruits de claques)
D'accord ?
S'il fait une introduction,
s'il la prend dans ses bras,
il a plus de chance d'être accepté.
C'est pareil quand on parle en public.
Une belle intro, je vous rappelle,
c'est une histoire,
une anecdote, une citation,
une affirmation très forte qui va
soit vous bouleverser
émotionnellement, soit vous choquer.
Ensuite,
on part dans le concret.
Il y a un plan et une promesse.
Mon plan à moi, c'est trois histoires,
trois conférenciers.
Ma promesse,
vous donner trois questions
pour que, vous aussi, vous
puissiez être plus inspirants,
plus clairs et plus structurés.
Ensuite, il y a des explications.
C'est ce que je suis
en train de faire : j'explique.
C'est mon contenu.
Et chaque fois qu'on explique,
il faut illustrer,
sinon, on s'endort -
on endort son public en tout cas.
Et après, on entend
des conférenciers dire :
« Le public était froid ! »
Non, en fait !
Juste toi qui étais froid.
Une fois qu'on a expliqué
et illustré, c'est très simple :
on dit : « Au revoir »
d'une très belle façon,
avec une conclusion qui sera
aussi forte que l'introduction.
Là, on a couvert toutes
les zones du cerveau,
et avec ça, je peux vous dire que vos
interventions seront nettement meilleures.
Je vais vous proposer
une illustration métaphorique
de ce que je viens de vous dire.
C'est un sandwich :
une tranche de pain, très solide -
c'est l'intro -
tout va se baser dessus.
Si vous n'y êtes pas bon,
tout le monde prend son téléphone
et regarde YouTube.
Ensuite, il y a le plan
et la promesse.
Il y a le contenu -
c'est un bon steak.
Il y a de belles tomates
pour les illustrations.
Et puis, évidemment, en conclusion,
un autre bout, pour qu'on
puisse bien le manger,
sinon tout va s'écrouler.
Ça,
c'est une prise de parole raisonnable :
deux messages-clés -
on pourrait en mettre un troisième.
Ça, c'est l'indigestion.
Et le problème, c'est que
c'est souvent comme ça.
Quand on écoute des gens parler,
ils sont tellement généreux
qu'ils vous donnent beaucoup de choses,
et vous dans la salle,
vous vous dites : « Han...
Qu'est-ce que je prends ?
Qu'est-ce que je mange ? »
Un peu de ça, un peu de ça, et au final,
qu'est-ce que j'ai retenu ?
Christine Morlet,
la question qu'elle se pose, c'est :
« Qu'est-ce que je veux
que les gens retiennent ? »
Et c'est ma troisième question-clé.
Qu'est-ce que je veux
que les gens retiennent ?
Je vais vous donner encore une
méthode - je suis Madame Méthode.
Vous allez prendre une feuille blanche,
écrire tout ce qui vous passe par la tête
en répondant à la question « Qu'est-ce
que je veux qu'ils retiennent ? »
Ensuite, vous allez hiérarchiser.
Souvent, dans la majorité des cas,
le point n°1 n'est jamais le bon,
Alors il va descendre dans le classement,
et le reste va remonter.
Et là, vous allez prendre les 1, 2 et 3.
C'est tout.
1, 2, 3, vous gardez ça,
et le reste, c'est pour autre chose.
C'est pour une autre intervention,
mais ce n'est pas pour aujourd'hui.
Si vous faites ça,
vous deviendrez bien plus
performant en prise de parole en public.
Tous ces conférenciers
ont un grand point commun.
Évidemment,
ils accordent autant d'importance
au fond
qu'à la forme.
C'est Victor Hugo qui disait déjà :
« La forme, c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface. »
On doit tous accorder beaucoup
d'importance au fond et à la forme.
Si mes mots sont magnifiques
mais qu'ils sont figés
par une posture très figée,
ça ne passera pas.
Alors, à partir d'aujourd'hui
ou à partir de demain,
pensez à ces trois questions :
qu'est-ce que je veux
que les gens ressentent ?
Retiennent ?
Fassent ?
Accordez autant d'importance
au fond qu'à la forme.
Et vous aussi, vous deviendrez
des conférenciers très inspirants.
Et si ce n'est pas des conférenciers,
au moins des orateurs
inspirants, clairs
et structurés.
Et pour que vous le compreniez bien,
j'ai mis au point une petite danse.
Vous êtes prêts ? C'est ma surprise.
Vous vous rappelez la conclusion ?
Marquante et frappante.
Eh bien, chiche !
Je vais vous montrer.
Après, vous allez vous lever,
il y aura de la musique,
et on va tous danser ensemble.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Prêts ?
Public : Oui !
OK, merci.
Alors,
la chorégraphie est très très simple.
Qu'est-ce que je veux qu'ils ressentent ?
Qu'ils retiennent ?
Qu'est-ce que je veux qu'ils fassent ?
C'est parti ?
On y va !
(Musique)